it is the end of an era for TV
institution the game-changing show that
gave us Kelly Clarkson Carrie Underwood
and so many more crown to it it's final
champion last night didn't feel like a
big class reunion it was like everybody
back together former judges contestant
everybody was there and of course et was
backstage for the star-studded curtain
call what does it mean to you to be a
part of history the final season the
final broadcast ever just being part of
the show is being part of history
show-stopping JLo kicking off our Idol
finale by the numbers the singer rocked
three performance looks last night
changing right on stage 50s housewife
Vegas showgirl had sheer bodysuit and
there was so much star power
34 finalists returned and all 14 past
winners were featured
including Kelly Clarkson and Carrie
Underwood
seven former judges help celebrate Allen
Nicki Minaj and Steven Tyler take video
tributes Kara DioGuardi performed but
this was what we were all waiting for
when slammin came out and was up there
with Randy and Paula and Ryan that was
pretty cool because we all have such
amazing memories of this show in its
early years for all of us to be back
together on that stage dude come on
oh my heart melted over and over in
seing the contestants and of course my
compadres former judge Mariah Carey did
not participate she was busy in concert
on her world tour in Latvia next big
number
the ratings a solid season high of
almost 13 million folks tuned in but of
course it all came down to one winner
Trent Haaga
what was going through your mind in not
only the silence before Ryan spoke but
when he said your name uh you know I
said a little prayer right before all of
it and I told Porsche I said Porsche
whatever happens let's just hug and not
even care what they say and she agreed
however for you hearing once again the
song that you co-wrote now is an idle
coronation it was too realized just on
the phone to neck and I said to well she
was saying to somebody that's the song
you wrote and it was incredible to have
him up there singing that everybody
singing along with it so it's thrilled
and for runner up love porscha renee
this was pretty cool one winner but two
record deals okay right after you came
off stage they were like oh by the way
with us by the way we have some good
news your sana Motown and being seen and
nice new records anyways oh my god okay
Wow
you
you